a wizard is never late for their beggins
nor is he early he probably just didn't
know this movie was
a thing seriously did you know you
didn't know where did this movie come
from at the time i was blissfully
watching batman mask with the phantasm
uploading that video then there were the
comments like where's
where's your review of the power movie
anyhow you wanted me to watch it and
review it so i watched it i got my tools
so now we review it apple juice remember
[Music]
what is this movie called project power
right so project power it sounds like a
superhero movie it's not really a
superhero movie
it's a movie that has a superhero
concept in it
but they were like you know what we
don't really have the budget for it so
it's not really a superhero movie or
maybe they did i don't know i don't know
what the budget for this movie was i
suppose i could look it up
but am i going to [ __ ] no so the concept
is it takes place in new orleans there's
this new drug on the street and you take
the pill
and you get a random superpower it's a
random grab bag you can be invisible you
can be
super strong super tough super fast it
could just blow you up
could make you turn into fire which
means the first guy i saw in this movie
and
he's all combusted into flames and he's
charging after jamie foxx and i was like
holy [ __ ]
it's the phantom pain it's what i
thought so the plot is jamie foxx is
trying to he's going up the ladder you
know he's trying to find the guy behind
the guy behind the guy of this whole
operation joseph gordon-levitt plays a
cop
again jamie foxx is the one that really
carries this movie it's the jamie foxx
show joseph gordon-levitt is fine in the
movie but it doesn't stand out to me as
much as jamie foxx does
i feel like this thing is clacking
around if that bothers you i'm so sorry
it's so it keeps the drink cold
but there's no ice that can melt so the
apple juice doesn't get diluted
it's very important and this movie is a
textbook case
of all style no substance but the
premise is awesome because the premise
is pretty sweet
a pill that gives you a random
superpower lasts five minutes so
it's not like people always have it you
can see a new wave of drug distribution
you could have
super criminals out there wearing dare
t-shirts trying to keep the drugs out of
the hands of the heroes i saw potential
in this movie
that's the thing this movie is all the
potential none of the reality really
all flash no substance and when it's
flashy it's really entertaining it's
the flash is not wasted when someone
takes a pill it does that requiem for a
dream snap snap snap the eye dilates
only minus the heroin the powers are
usually pretty cool and you're
entertained for that moment there's a
goldilocks
zone to hit in there though you know you
don't want to overuse the superpowers
because then it's not cool when it's
used but you want to use it enough so
we're not just completely bored but they
don't quite hit the zone i appreciate
the fact they don't overuse the powers
but i will say i could have gone for a
couple more scenes with super powers
because really what it is is jamie foxx
and this
girl that he's essentially kidnapped i
mean their pals and friends are just
helping him out but you know it's this
batman and robin kind of scenario
as said in the movie no batman and robin
that's a movie this is real life well in
the end they're just
chasing a trail joseph gordon-levitt
comes along and he's chasing a trailer
stuff at the beginning of the movie
some at the end of the movie and in the
middle of this big zone where
just people going after people i've seen
that [ __ ] a hundred times before in
movies like i know new movies aren't
coming out right now and you know so
it's kind of a big deal like everyone
slams on the bricks like whoa new movie
but this movie's just kind of
it happened and then next week we will
have forgotten about it and it's pretty
much the same outcome that would have
happened if movies were coming out in
theaters this would have gotten just
lost in the rabble of movies
because it's not really that special it
doesn't stand out it's
it's directed by the guy who directed
that movie nerve you remember nerve yeah
right there you go that kind of
nerve style and flash admittedly i like
nerve more than i like this movie which
is
why we have this i'm just trying to give
the movie the benefit of the doubt
i need more benefit here we go it really
actually looks like
that vincent chase movie in the
entourage movie that he was directing
oh just it feels like that and there
were some times where people got powers
you know by the end so like all right
the pill
wrecked him for a dream and all that all
right now we're coming after him and
it's like someone got a superpower
because when making the movie they were
like
look we need to throw in a superpower so
a couple times it was just
long enough to shut the audience up this
movie needed more time to marinate to be
honest with you i mean from the
beginning
this guy's like okay i'm a super drug
dealer and here's this new super drug
and it's the drug that gives people
superpowers
and then it's like it jumps six weeks
later or something like that so joseph
gordon live at the cops they kind of
know about this substance i feel like
the most interesting part of this story
is that first six weeks that the movie
just skips over
in that it probably would have been a
more interesting series and i'm still
interested in the world of this movie i
just i
didn't think the movie was good i still
don't maybe i will hold on
nope and now i'm out [ __ ]
oh come on more than that yeah there we
go so i see potential in the world of
this movie i want them to press forward
and tell more stories from this world
let's hope for a series i mean
it's a netflix movie it can be a netflix
series in the end i'll say
power pilled what's it called yeah i'm
obviously not gonna remember it in
t-minus one day
yep already forgot there you go people
requesting a review for this movie
there's your review
i hope it was worth it and just so i
don't run into the scenario of people
wanting me to review new mutants
when it comes out or tan it i want to
see them
but washington state's pretty locked
down
still and so i guess these movies are
coming to theaters and
there are no theaters in washington to
show them so
if that remains the case and your
friends are like where's jeremy's review
kindly defer them to this video where i
have now explained it
cheers alright so project
power have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see
[Music]
more
you